I was a little cheesy back in the night
like if you're over 30 I don't know you
remember that one asshole in the club
with just a vest on who goes out with
just a vest like what are you han Solo
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. we all have
that special woman in our life the one
we like to put up on a pedestal finger
sandwiches boy oh thank you mom go make
it rain
[Applause]
now make sure you separate the ones from
the five now I gotta pick up some money
if I rate the Beatles
that's my boy Joel known as the host of
the year on the list podcast you know
from a comedy album American comic
everybody
[Music]
I'm actually dedicating this story to my
mom it's a story about her catching me
jerking off listen I'm a comic
all right I don't write songs or poems
I'm dedicating a jerk-off story to my
mom all right that's the extent well I
was raised by a single mom and she had
three boys you know and it's hard for
moms to try you know to try to talk to
his sons about the animalistic we
do you know I mean like my little
brother and me we're animals my older
brother was a little bit nicer and knew
how to act he was a boy he was gay so it
makes sense you know gay guys know how
to act literally they're amazing actors
but I met they know how to behave but we
never had to talk I mean I learned how
to be with women from like R&B videos
and porn and my little brother learned
from me so when you raise his sons you
know they can't you doing messed up
you know I remember one time I hid my
rubbers remember you never hide your
rubbers you know because I don't wanted
to know but then one time I opened my
drawer and they were there perfectly
folded in the drawer so she let me know
she knew but didn't never said anything
when moms catch you rubber went out they
don't say like I've been caught a few
times by my mom and by my wife
but I'm saying like well your mom
catches nos ain't like if your wife
catches you you know now there's a
problem now we have to have a sit-down
you know what I mean is there a problem
in a relationship you know moms are cool
I remember one time I was rubbing one
out my mom walked in she's like hey
Brett okay turn around and left nothing
was ever set you know what I mean so I'm
home from college like I was one of
those losers that went away to Community
College I mean like I went to Community
College in another town acting like I I
was doing with my life so I come
home from Community College and and it's
a Wednesday night we're going out on a
Wednesday night because you know that's
what you do when you're in Community
College and my friends are picking me up
they're like yo we're gonna we're gonna
go out we're gonna go down to Miami you
know so get ready to go out so you know
and you know and by the way I'm a
reformed Guido guy there was an
intervention like 99 they took my
cologne bottles away but you know I was
a little cheesy back in the day like if
you're over 30 I don't know you remember
that one asshole in the club with just a
vest on who goes out with just a vest
like what are you han Solo the and
I would wear timberland boots like that
would offset the vest like yeah I do
construction after I fly the Millennium
Falcon
so my boys are getting ready to pick me
up so you know I'm doing my pre going
out rituals shaving the chest Cologne
doc did my curls got the vest on and I
mean I'm ready to go out so now we go
pre drinking there was this club down it
was like a little ways down for me was
it was called crickets right it was a it
was a real all like people got
stabbed there whatever but you know we
would pre drink there and then we would
head down to to Miami to go out so we
get to the bar vests everywhere you know
I mean it's jumping and as soon as I get
in there I make eye contact with this
girl right beautiful girl cute strong
sex you know I mean so I see all right I
go i zero in on it you know I'm like I
just walked right up to him like a hey
how you doing you know what's your name
she's like Francesca I gave Francesca
how's it going so I'm talking to her
we're doing shots you know getting
hammered then my friends come up to me
and they're like yo we're gonna go down
to Miami let's bounce you know and I'm
like all right I go to the girl can I
get you number well and she's like well
why don't you stay I'm like well they're
my ride I got no way of getting back and
then she's like I'll take you home
I'm like all right I told my boys to
bounce you know what I mean by the way
we didn't have a looper back then either
all right I strung six was your uber so
now we're drinking we're getting
hammered right she's like you know let
me take you home so we drive back to the
house and again I'm drunk you know you
know you slamming around and we lived in
a little apartment so I'm making noise
and then either the lights go on and I
woke my mom up right and my mom had like
she had that mob Robie ever see the mom
robe it's like she's like what are you
doing you know you'll go to bed Carol
like what are you doing up you know
she's like you know who's your friend
I'm like uh Francesca is my mom Manas is
Francesca you know so I can I make you
guys something to eat I'm like no so my
mom goes back to sleep now Francesca was
half Italian and half Spanish all right
so she understood the family thing you
know what I mean cuz the fact that she
met my mom now the whole dynamic changed
you know cuz cuz I'm making out with her
and we're fooling around but it's just
not the same she's like you know I can't
do this you know your mom's in the other
room I'm like Carol don't care don't
worry about you know a man we're still
going and she's like I can't I feel
disrespectful I'm like you know so she
gave me your number so hit me up later
and she left so now I'm alone with a
worked-up p-xylene
alright so this is where it goes south
now this is back in the VCR days by the
way okay
they had DVD players but I was still
working with VCR well well I amassed
like this huge VHS collection okay and
you know back then you you had a porn
tape like that you know he was on a VHS
tape but I had so many tapes that I
would hide my tape in plain sight so
like my mom would never find it you know
like my porn tape said NFL's greatest
hits on yeah I mean I found my older
brothers one time I'm like I haven't
seen Greece in a while
anyways so and that's the other thing
you didn't have internet porn back then
alright you had a VHS tape that you
passed around to your friends and when
you put it in you saw exactly where he
finished which made it really awkward
right you gotta rewind it and find your
own little scene so I got NFL's greatest
hits in the VCR right and now I decide I
got to get one off you know what I mean
and I'm the whiskey's really kicking it
I'm hammered room spinning so I get
butt-naked okay and I'm laying in bed
now I don't know if you ever do this or
not when you're rubbing one out in bed
but you ever make like that toilet paper
runway you know what I mean it's
relevant to this it's relevant to this
story yeah I mean like never make that
toilet paper runway it's like nice quick
easy cleanup you just throw it out of
the bed wake up the next morning get rid
of the evidence nobody knows nothing
right so I'm laying there butt naked
covered in Charmin two-ply because I
knew who's going to be a strong one
right
I got my little root in my hand I'm
literally maybe five strokes in right
I'm so drunk I pass out now when I wake
up the next morning okay the TV's off
and I'm tucked in my bed
[Applause]
Magne know when you were like you know
you were out drinking the night before
you ever get really drunk and then you
wake up the next morning there's like 10
seconds what you forgot you were
drinking yeah then you realize you were
drunk and start praying to God for
things that don't exist like oh god
please let there be little magical
jerk-off else that came in here to clean
me up and I can imagine my poor mom just
just imagine being a mom walking in
seeing her son laying there covered in
toilet paper like some perverted mummy
with just a vest on and she's never said
a word to this day which is why I love
my mom